hello everybody markiplier here giving
you an update on the borderlands 2
giveaway if your case you didn't know we
got three games I've got three games at
Borderlands 2 that I'm gonna give away
to you guys so that you guys can either
play with me or play on your own or do
whatever and it's all based on how many
times you share my video now here's the
statistics so far there have been 1435
shares legitimate shares so far I had to
discount some because some people out
there while you know I appreciate the
effort you've become quite fami
a small number of people have take it
upon themselves to spam certain places
so I I generally discount those and I
should have discouraged it early on in
the original V log but yeah I don't want
this sharing to be something that's
annoying to others I mean I'm all about
getting the word out but people should
be able to determine whether something
is spam or not so anyway here is the
bucket I've upgraded it a bit since last
time fitful another I've upgraded it
once more since the last picture I
showed up this is 1435 entries but
here's the funny bit here's the kicker
there's only 89 only 89 individuals that
have shared there are 89 individual
names in this bucket which breaks down
to an average of about 16 a little over
16 shares per person now there's some
with more and there's some with less but
the most the person with the most shares
currently and because of the whole spam
thing I've had to like adjust numbers on
the fly
but the person in first place I'm not
gonna say their name but the person in
first place has 127 shares and that
person has gone crazy sharing in
different places on the internet he
sends me pictures on forums on the
Facebook on his friends Facebook pages
he send me a picture of an in-game mail
in world of warcraft that he sent to his
guild mates he sent all sorts of crazy
crazy different places that i would
never have thought of to share so that's
that's the kind of stuff encouraged and
other things that I kind of
I had to knock down a couple of is
because it was just a bit spammy but I
really do appreciate the effort that you
guys have done to help me out and in
case you didn't notice the subscriber
count' this week has been astonishing
because if you guys remember last week I
just hit 5,000 and we're at five
thousand nine hundred and sixteen which
is nine hundred sixteen gained in a week
which equals a hundred and thirty one
subscribers a day on average well I
guess if you oh hey hang on let me do
that again
because it's Saturday and I think we hit
it on Friday but so let me do that by
eight days instead oh gosh it's only 114
subscribers per day okay
it's so much worse I guess I can ignore
everything else that happened but no
like seriously you guys you have done an
incredible job just the 89 people and
only 89 people have actually shared
anything on any of my videos or if they
have if more have only 89 people have
submitted their names to the bucket so
just think of what like could happen to
this channel if everyone who watches
this video contributes just one share
just one that would be astonishing and
if you're worried about you know oh I
only have a 1 in 5,000 chance of winning
this proves that you don't there's
actually a much better chance if there's
like I mean the guy who has the most
have 127 shares but that still doesn't
put him at an exorbitant percentage to
win like most people in here generally
shared about 10 times that was usually
the ballpark number that I got most of
the time other people shared once or
twice and I appreciate that
like I appreciate everything you guys do
but this this promotion is working like
really really working and I can't help
but be once again I want to use the word
flabbergasted at the response so thank
you guys so much for everything that
you're doing to help grow this channel
it's just exponential how big we're
getting like so quickly it's outrageous
I mean I was I was thinking like because
the peak day the the biggest day that we
had
over the past week has been like I I
think I got 168 subscribers in a single
day which was like oh my god they keep
running in because I get email updates
every time I get a new subscriber and my
phone was just buzzing all day and it's
it's it's a good feeling to share my
phone it goes another subscriber cuz I
check every single email I get i I check
every single comment on every video that
people make so I really I really am
watching and if I can't respond to
everyone personally but I if you type
something I am reading it so keep that
in mind now it's usually good I mean
there have been some occasions where
people think that fans of mine are
spamming but I can I'm overlooking that
for now because it's not a big deal I've
never listened to haters I've never
listened to people have been negative
towards me never because it doesn't
bother me because what really matters at
the end of the day is providing
entertainment for you guys the ones who
do enjoy my videos every day and that's
that at the end of the day I've always
advocated that's what matters
so long as I can entertain you I don't
care what everyone else says I don't
care what anyone else thinks of me so
long as some of you are enjoying my
videos and if but you know if gets to
the point where a lot of you don't enjoy
many of you I'm doing something wrong a
nice abroad chain but so far things have
been going great so that's all that I
have to say about that and we've got a
week left you've got a week one week
from today I'll do it on Saturday just
because it's easier to doing I usually
have free time and I've got classes on
Friday and stuff like that and usually
I'm out drinking at bars or whatever I
kind of have a social life but on
Saturday I will do this drawing I'll
probably I need to upgrade this bucket
because this one's full now I'll get a
bigger bowl even the more and if you
guys if more people want to contribute
like don't think it's hopeless that you
can't win because I just showed you the
numbers it's very possible for you to
still win there's only 89 people that
have shared there's only 89 names in
this bucket so if you want to get your
name in go right ahead you're on
Facebook Twitter funnyjunk
reddit 9gag anything else anything you
can think of full gaming forums anything
like that and get your name in the
bucket so that you can win the copy
Borderlands 2 and get to play with me
and once again the person who shares the
most and there's one person who was way
ahead of the pack
127 they'll get to play another game
with me so I'll be fine oh and I wanted
to do something for my my fans over on
the tumblr who likes to make gifts out
of my face
so I want to give you an opportunity to
make a bunch of gifts of mine so here we
go okay that good enough is that enough
need some more okay that's enough I
dunno about that don't want to give you
all too excited so anyway this has been
a long view log so I'm gonna cut it now
so thank you guys so much for everything
that you've done I really do appreciate
everything that you guys do and I get
more excited every day because I get to
wake up and do this it's it's just an
incredible feeling I mean it sucks
because I start school on Monday and I
have to get up and go to my 8 a.m. class
so that'd be unfortunate but I'm still
gonna dedicate myself like three videos
a day that's what I've been doing that's
what I've been sticking to some days I
do too when I'm like really busy and I'm
like out and I didn't record the land
before and I don't have videos up or I'm
getting upload problems or stuff like
that but I really really really really
love to do this I I I can't tell you how
excited I am to do this every day it's
just the greatest feeling in the world
coming up to entertain you oh and today
we're recording more drunk minecraft we
got I got your suggestions from my
Facebook poll if you don't know I I do
polls on Facebook like all the time a
couple times a week asking you guys what
I should play what I should do so if you
want to keep in touch with me follow me
on twitter follow me on Facebook and my
Twitter is not an upload bots anymore I
actually post about my daily life now
I'm not going to do I'm not gonna make
it so it automatically tweets whenever I
upload a video I'm actually responding
to people so if you want to talk with me
directly I'm trying to keep up with
every tweet that I get and
respond to every tweet that I get so
follow me on Twitter if you want to keep
up with me so thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next video bye bye